they're now months into the pandemic now
and local doctors are learning more
about how to treat Cova 19 patients from
those with mild symptoms to the most
extreme cases our Bianca Holman spoke
with medical experts and she is live
with more hi Bianca hey good morning
Alex from having no symptoms at all to
ending up on a villain or later many
people of course why I've been tested
for kovat 19 and wonder what does
recovery look like so we reached out to
local doctors here in the area to ask
them about that the local doctors tell
us that symptoms can vary from person to
person but from 2 to 14 days after
person has been exposed to the virus
many people can experience a fever cough
lost of taste or smell if you find
yourself tested positive no emergency
symptoms like trouble breathing or chest
pains the CDC recommends getting rest
staying hydrated or remaining in one
room of your home and keeping surfaces
clean to protect the spread to others
dr. Lipman an infectious disease
specialist says while the majority of
people who get kovat 19 will recover and
do well there's still a percent that end
up hospitalized the important thing is
to remember that we need to continue to
practice this social distancing continue
to wear masks try to interrupt the
spread of the virus as best we can and
especially if you have been diagnosed
with the infection you know it's more
incumbent on you to take appropriate
precautions to try to avoid spreading it
to other family members friends
co-workers and while doctors are
learning more and more about the virus
daily we asked about the antibody
testing that's really come up a lot
lately and dr. Lipman says it's only
suggested if you've recovered from koban
19 and you want to donate plasma now if
you feel that you've been exposed or may
have some of those symptoms that we
talked about of course on our website 8
News now.com we have several stories
about testing locations throughout the
valley reporting live from Decatur and
metals Lane Bianca Holman
eight moons now